salut à tous j'espère que vous passez
des bonnes vacances alors là je fais
juste une petite annonce pour introduire
la vidéo qui va suivre qui n'est pas un
JDG c'est juste une toute petite vidéo
bonus qu'on met parce que là on était en
vacances au mois de juillet là on était
en vacances du coup on n' pas fait de
vidéo là au moment où vous regardez
cette vidéo on est en train de reprendre
l'écriture pour la vidéo de qu'on va
travailler en aoû qui du coup sortira
début septembre donc voilà tout ça pour
vous dire que ce que vous allez regarder
n'est pas un vrai JDG c'est une toute
petite vidéo donc ne vous attendez pas à
quelque chose d'exceptionnel c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait fait très vite
il y a plusieurs mois de ça donc donc du
coup voilà vous êtes prévenu vous aurez
pas de mauvaises surprises du coup on se
retrouve le mois prochain en septembre
du coup pour un vrai JDG et je vous
souhaite d'ici de continuer à passer de
super vacances parce que pour nous elles
sont finis salut à
tous salut à tous c'est joueurs du
grenier il paraît que vous passez un bon
moment et en tant que connard je ne peux
pas laisser passer ça laissez-moi donc
vous gâcher la soirée en vous montrant
que non la vie c'était pas mieux avant
elle puait elle puit comme maintenant et
ça je vais vous le montrer à travers une
liste non ex d'éléments non hiérarchisés
ayant pour thème un dénominateur commun
le jeu vidéo
ouais un top quoi ouais un
top la guerre des consoles vous m'avez
tous fait perdre un temps monstrueux à
essayer d'argumenter que Mario était
plus fort que Sonic et blab bla bla
alors que finalement que ce soit les
fans de Nintendo ou les fans de Sonic la
guerre des consoles on l' tous perdu
face à une paire de nichon pointu mais
cela dit on va rétablir la vérité tout
le monde pensait que Mario c'était pour
les gosses et que Sonic c'était le
rebelle maintenant oubliez les
graphismes mignons Mario déjà il libère
pas les animaux il les butent et ensuite
c'est quand même un mec qui monte sur un
dinosaure qui crache du feu et qui mange
des gens et qui hésite pas à sacrifier
son copain dinosaure si ça l'aide à
franchir des gouffres et si on lit le
livret les briques d'un Mario c'est les
habitants du royaume champignons
transformés en briqu donc en plus
considérrez qu'il profane des tombes
tout ça pour un plan cul ah oui etend
j'y suis les
[ __ ] il a 10 bit les bits ni vous ni
moi on savait ce que c'était alors il
est temp de rétablir une vérité le
nombre de bits ne sert à
rien le mec qui a glouscé foutez le
d'hors et vous voulez une preuve
attention les images de la
[Musique]
Jaguar 64
bits souffler dans les cartouches ça
servait à rien et oui les mecs désolé de
vous le dire c'était une légende si vous
souffliez dans vos cartouches c'est
parce que vous avez vu un pote à vous
souffler dans sa cartouche et si votre
pote souffle aussi dans sa cartouche
c'est parce qu'il avait vu un autre pote
à lui souffler dans sa
cartouche mais du coup qui a été le
premier à souffler dans une
[Musique]
cartouche la Playstation j'adore la
Playstation c'était ma console préférée
et pourtant objectivement autant
j'arrive à rejouer un Super Mario World
autant pour rejouer un des premiers jeux
en 3D non mais c'est hardcore hein et je
parle même pas de tous les trucs géniaux
que votre mémoire sélective a
complètement effac
os et le stress quand vous LZ un je
quand le C avait traîné pendant mois sur
une
[Musique]
table
lance-toi lance-toi lance-toi
[Musique]
lance-toi et de toutes les Strade qu'on
appliquit quand ça marchait pas mettre
la console à l'envers mettre le logo PS1
vers le bas mettre de sur la lentille et
ces boîtes de merde aussi là vous faites
un concours de fragilité avec les boîtes
Super NES heureusement il y avait des
énormes avantages comme lire la musique
sur la
télé attends il y avait même le mode
Church pour faire comme si tu écoutais
de la musique dans une église c'est
utile quand tu habites tes potes curé
waouh c'est comme sur ma chaîne IFI en
moins
bien les boîtes de jeux [ __ ] de merde
je déteste les créateurs des boîtes de
jeux vous êtes la définition des escroc
mais pour rappelle quand on allait
acheter un jeu avant il y avait pas le
net et du coup tu te FIA à la jaquette
wou regardez cette jaquette c'est un
super magicien [ __ ] de musclé qui
balance des éclaires oh comme j'achète
trop
direct et je parle même pas de la beauté
de certaines jaquettes alors je vais pas
parler de celle que tout le monde
connaît du genre megga Man en version
souposu ou Mario version PSTAR des
années 80 parce que pour moi les vrais
champions de la jaquette ils étaient
chez ces gars alors on avait Bill
Clinton baseball nazi Transformers un
mec décapité qui fait une prise à une
tête je sais pas le dessin de ta petite
sœur le jeu où le titre n'a rien à voir
avec l'image qui n'a rien à voir avec le
jeu et évidemment le jeu qui rend
hommage à l'œeuvre
originelle survivant de
l'enfer souvent C
[Musique]
leire bon après au moins les jaquettes
elles étaient moches mais ça résistait
merci de m'avoir rendu mon jeu super
c'est
cool les jeux électroniques [ __ ] quand
j'entends quelqu'un dire mais oui mais
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ils auront pas
la chance de jouer à
ça
ah merde vous devez être tellement
dégoûté les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ça va
vous Batz pas trop vous connaîtrez
jamais la joie de torcher le cul de
tamagi tous les 2hures ou de la
profondeur de game play donne ses
machins [ __ ] que c'était NAS déjà pour
commencer ces [ __ ] de pileron tu en
avais jamais ensuite c'était nul et pour
finir maman quand je te demander de
m'acheter une Game Boy et que tu me
ramenais ça à la place non c'est pas
pareil le seul point sur lequel je suis
d'accord c'est que les jeunes de
maintenant n'auront pas la chance de
voir ces pubs les jeux qu'on préfère à
transporter galère tu connais pas Tiger
ninja gu de non ça tient dans ta main
pendant ne niveaux bat-toi pour ta vie
bat-toi bat-toi contre tes ennemis ball
police Academie football Tiger la force
dans ta
poche les émissions de jeux vidéo à la
télé ça aussi c'était pas mieux avant en
plus c'est plus cool maintenant les
émissions es sont présentées par un vrai
vampire osez me dire que c'est pas un
vampire alors il y a les très vieilles
émissions sur le jeu vidéo où on
imaginait les joueurs comme des mecs
avec des casques en papier àu qui
pilotent des vaisseaux avec un guidon
mais je parle pas de celle-là je parle
des émissions un peu plus récentes déjà
je rêve de retrouver une des nous qui
avait réussi à jouer à Hugo délire pour
lui exploser la tête sur le coin de
meuble pointu à droite va à droite va à
droite mais [ __ ] mais il y a une carte
c'est pas compliqué de lire une [ __ ]
de carte espèce de
gourde après je parlerai pas de tvisate
2 ou de micro kids mais d'une autre
émission qui m'a touché hell aujourd'hui
c'est un grand jour pour l'univers cber
on a fait des milliers de recr que dis
des millions dans le monde entier vous
trouvez pas ça étonnant étonnant outre
le fait qu'on dirait le héros de Little
Big aventure qui se travestit en femme
mais sérieusement pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
l'ont mise à poil non parce qu'on vient
de pas me dire que c'est juste un peu
moulant ça c'est du body pain je trouve
ça tellement dégradant pour la condition
de la femme allez maintenant quelque
chose pour vous
aider on s'en fout remetteznous les
nichons les consoles portables c'est
super la game la LyX on peut jouer où on
veut mais surtout chez soi en fait à
moins d'avoir des actions dans
l'industrie des piles après la Game Boy
effectivement tu pouvais jouer dehors
mais soyez honnête c'était dégueulasse
la Game Boy en extérieur c'est simple tu
voyais rien du tout tu étais obligé de
te contentionner dans tous les sens pour
éviter les reflets sur l'écran alors bon
tu me diras il y avait la loupe mais bon
je pense qu'elle était déjà vendue
salele parce qu'elle était tout le temps
dégueulasse et c'était qu'un seul des
nombreux accessoires Game Boy
complètement pétés il y a eu le sonard
Game Boy pour pêcheur sans déconner ça
existe le P17 alors ça c'est un
accessoire qui te balançait du gaz pour
t'endormir dans la face ça existe aussi
bon c'était réservé pour les dentistes
par contre dommage que ça soit pas un
grand public j'aurais adoré les pubs
vas-y vas-y à toi de jouer tu sens même
pas le tbip toopéré mais mon préféré
c'était le glucoboy pour Game Boy
Advance glucoboy le diabète gluc le
glucoboy ça servait à mesurer le taux de
glucose pour les diabétiques en mettant
une petite goutte de sang dans
l'appareil en te faisant jouer un petit
jeu ouais j'espère que le jeu est pas
trop dur ou pas trop passionnant pour
continuer à jouer remettez du sang dans
l'appareil au final les consoles
portables j'ai joué chez moi
dans l'ombre
seul et tant qu'on est dans les
accessoir de merde on va continuer alors
je ne parle pas du zappeur de la N que
tout le monde a eu ni des trucs un peu
connus genre la webcam pour Game Boy ou
le Power glove mais plutôt des accessoir
que personne ne connaît tenez le
speedbard par exemple ça servait pour
poser la manette à plat j'ai un autre
truc moins
cher il y a la version hipster pour
Atari
aussi alors Nintendo n'est pas tout seul
ces gars aussi a sorti des accessoires
qui sont beaucoup moins connus le Sega
activator par exemple c'était un truc
composé au sol et qui servait à détecter
les mouvements pour l'appliquer en jeu
chaque angle du Bidu là correspondait
donc à une touche alors donc ce truc
n'est sorti qu'aux États-Unis là ce que
vous voyez c'est la pub donc moi je ne
l'ai pas testé mais par contre tu vas
clairement pas me faire croire que le
mec qui joue comme ça là est en train de
gagner contre le mec avec la manette non
non non ou alors toi tu pues la merde
vraiment et c'est même pas l'accessoire
le plus stupide regardez ça l'action
chair alors il y a la même sur NES c'est
une chaise où les mouvements de la croix
se font avec les mouvements des fesses
sur la chaise j'ai tellement envie de
voir un match entre un mec qui joue à
l'activator et un mec qui joue à
l'action
chair bref tout ça pour dire que non les
années 90 ça n'était pas mieux avant
c'était juste votre enfance ou mon
enfance et c'est pour ça qu'on l' trouvé
mieux il y avait pas de responsabilité
pas besoin de trouver du travail pas
besoin d' faire les courses et puis
maman te faisait à manger allez c'était
Joueur du Grenier je suis ravi d'avoir
gâché votre
soirée
[Musique]
quoi je déteste les années
90 tuas pas essuyer